regardez la première vidéo qu'on a reçu
cette année j'étais super sage
j'aimerais pour ton émission baba noël
tum organise une demande en mariage de
dagne ma chérie elle s'appelle des vies
ça fait 20 ans qu'on est ensemble on a
de superbes aux enfants on avait plus de
galère de moments de joie de bonheur
qu'on a vécu plein de choses mais ne
manquent vraiment ce mariage donc s'il
te plaît mon petit mano elle je te
demande de m'organiser une demande en
mariage de dingue
il voulait faire une demande en mariage
à [ __ ] alors restez avec nous vraiment
la finition vraiment que vous pouvez
regarder en famille vous allez adorer
alors là là tout tout tout les gens qui
sont autour de la table la shq
si vous pleurez pas sur cette séquence
non si c'est vraiment qui est un
problème on s'est dit mariage
donc on a demandé à benjamin castaldi
d'organiser la demande en mariage
benjamin a organisé cette demande en
mariage et regardez ce que ça a donné
c'est complètement ouf c'est parti
dix jeunes gens saouls
ici on my way le wagon sur scène il
s'arrêta folie il y aura des surprises
il y aura des cadeaux il y aura ben ça
lui arrive ça ça va ça va je pense très
cela quoi c'est aujourd'hui le dos et
l'astra 2000 a pour moi mais quoi c'est
aujourd'hui le dos c'est aujourd'hui
battant frère tu y vas y tu vas faire un
court de badminton avec il appelle je
sais si je fais ce que j'ai pu la seule
tu peux pas y aller comme ça écoute
moitié ce que tu vas faire
ouais je veux dire tu vas y aller avec
le spécialiste tu vas y aller avec
benjamin castaldi abbaoui benjamin
castaldi ou pas avec ax l'inversé seuls
d'accord et il s'occupe de ça je le fais
un don prison c'est je fais pas de
chance 0 6 à 3
sécurité avec lui
cet ep dit toi je me sens qui va
t'arriver un truc de ouf je les gels
bits pour ça allait passer mais ça bon
courage soient bradés vos noms et
croustade du coup ma chérie je l'aurais
compris ce soir il aura pas de tels
gestes le film de notre vie
toi et moi il ya 20 ans le premier
baiser en espagne sur les marches du
musée de salvador dali depuis ce baiser
perdure beaucoup de jouer avec nos
enfants
thalys qui naissent irelia avec notre
petit ange car la partie trop vite
tu me comble chaque jour de bonheur
d'amour
c'est pour toutes ces raisons j'ai juste
te dire que la fin notre fille ou ne
sera pas c'est marièrent kurt heureux et
eurent beaucoup d'enfants
le plus tôt ils furent heureux et eurent
beaucoup d'enfants et se marièrent ma
chérie
du sort
merci baba
non
elle s'attarde pas tous soir mais chut
wahou
à
alexandre p 10 fautes avec très
franchement c'est pas une bonne demande
en mariage sera pas trop visible à la
lame et noir tu suis tellement une bonne
cliente des larmes je vais dégueulasse
dans deux secondes pegi pegi n'est pas
bien trop rêver pas peggy d'ailleurs
vous êtes ça me fait rêver
quoi c'est vrai c'est génial ce que tu
as fait pour elle s'est mariée dit oui
si maxime jedid a fait ça ouais je pense
que oui même max il gagne à women me
owen n'a pas trop beaux joyaux fois à
oui j'ai mal à la racine et le patin
droit peut-être rester jusqu'à la fin
d'émission sera peut-être lui brise
isabelle à bout mais où je les trouve
très touchant de tourine 2 bravo hein
pas un amour et me fallait que c'est le
meilleur film meilleur et surtout grâce
à vous tous merci beaucoup deux énormes
et nous avoir de cette chance nous ça
nous a fait super plaisir et les chéris
vous avez un voyage de noces de prêt ou
pas yj choï mariage bon vous nous direz
vous partir en voyage de noces parce que
moi j'ai peut-être un truc moi ça vous
dirait de partir à dubaï eh ben vous
partez à 10
si tu étais
un peu plus tôt